so let me wait wait so you said that you
went to college and you were doing this
in college if you knew from the third
grade that this is what you wanted to do
what did you study in college well i i i
it's one of those things
well i was given some very good advice
by the guy who eventually became my
william morris agent he says do not quit
college now he said and as a comic you
know you have to be a certain age before
you've reached a stride eddie murphy
there are a couple of exceptions but you
have to have lived a certain amount of
time to have had enough life experiences
to really get it you know what i mean
right and at age
what are you in college 18 19 20 years
old you're an idiot you know what i mean
but you were doing it since you were but
you were already making a living yeah
but it was comedy i was a ventriloquist
but you're not really funny until you
know
until you've had you know and that's
what i tell people you know on agt we
have people on who have done
ventriloquism and we have people and you
know that we had darcy won but she was
an exception and it's the same thing as
impressionists i always say like maybe
you have the skill that you can do two
voices at once and maybe you have the
skill that you can do an impersonation
but you need the material right without
the material it doesn't it's nothing
well see again back to bergen that's why
it was funny because his writer was uh
brilliant the writers were great the
characterizations were believable the
situations they put them
them in in the radio broadcast that's it
was funny that was the point that's why
he was so popular so it was you know the
technique was secondary to the fact that
it was all good comedy so walter you you
did you have a did you draw a picture of
him no what happened was i went to the
ventriloquist convention here's a whole
nother
box of crap there's a ventriloquist
every summer yeah every summer we have
how many people
[Laughter]
we started there in 1975 there were 100
people that attended and now we're up to
600. times two are you including two
yeah times two yeah
are you the like you got to be the
epitome you got to be the main
i i guess i don't know yeah okay fine
but are you the like the closing
ceremony the speaker yeah i have a
lecture every year and uh you know a
lecture a lecture there's so many
different
aspects to what you do there's the
there's the acting you cause you have to
act and react and then you have to make
this person act and react
right yeah
yeah person thing it it character
whatever it is so there's a lot of
acting going on because you're not just
telling jokes you have to react to
whatever the other guy just said i bet
at the convention you see something that
it's so you've got to be polite and
everything but you probably see some
horrible well talk about open mic nights
at a comedy club okay let's do an open
mic night at a ventriloquist convention
oh my gosh you want to shoot yourself in
the head you really what is the weirdest
thing that you use
i want to go
this is the convention
there it is
there's a lot of charming lovely people
that go to that thing do you ever see
any real talented people oh sure
absolutely wait did you start this
convention you said when we oh look at
that there's me right there oh my lord
look at that how how many oh good
what's the weirdest thing you've seen at
the convention oh just stupid a talking
toilet
that's great just stupid it's like
you're writing jokes and they're all
puns you know i did a puppet you
remember i did it on stage eventually
so i had a i had a a toilet i had a
little potty oh no no i did and i stuck
my hand up through it and i had a brown
sock and it was winnie the pooh oh get
out of town where did you do that yuck
yucks in toronto but also you could also
do ventriloquist you could also talk
without opening your mouth you were able
to do that you could do the alphabet i
think i didn't do that yes you did you
also did it with a person on stage
[Music]
why so he's not a very articulate
ventriloquist no but you're amazing at
that when you watch you should have a
demo when you're in the room with jeff
and he is doing his act
even when you know as well as i know
jeff we've done shows together
you're not acting when walter's talking
i i truly believe that walter's talking
and i look at walter and i have no
qualms until after here come here
well my my
oh my gosh look at that what's that me
who made that me
that's great
this is hilarious howie the howie mandel
uh dummy yeah that's so scary
is it yeah yeah it's scary does his
mouth open no
well he's he can he can do nothing
without moving his lips
he can wave like say say goodbye to him
so he's the guy
but also he's waving right now
the howie dummy is throwing his voice
and you're the you're the dummy he looks
like mussolini with glasses on that's
kind of what you are talking about me or
the dummy
[Music]
you